what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and today
i will be talking about all of the crazy
news and speculation that the boku no
hero manga has already entered
its final arc if you've been paying
attention to the anime side of the
internet lately
then you know that after chapter 306 of
the mha manga
a ton of news articles and youtube
videos and social media posts in general
started talking about the manga coming
to an end in just
one more arc in this video i will be
breaking down
everything we know about the alleged
ending of mha
and i will be discussing where the story
will go from here
so stay tuned if you enjoyed the book no
hero content here on the channel you
want to keep it going please leave a
like to let me know it really does help
and if you're new to animal pro or maybe
just haven't subscribed yet make this
the video that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
before we get into it i want to give a
quick thank you to ragnarok
labyrinth for sponsoring this video
ragnarok labyrinth is a fast-moving
mmorpg that is free and really easy to
play
raise your hero whichever way you choose
by upgrading the jobs
gears cards and skills that you want
them to have
upgrade them to make them stronger and
use them to conquer dungeons and
boss raids you can also fight it out
with other players through brawls
duel battles and pvp leagues enjoy the
adorable animations and colorful
graphics
defeat the cute but scary monsters and
use the unique
share system to call your friends and
fight together against monsters and
bosses
or just fight each other in pvp mode
ragnarok labyrinth is a brand new game
they just launched on march 23rd so now
is the best time to start
playing click the top link in the
description to get started and if you
download the game
right now and use the special coupon
code labyrinth g
you will receive one costume box and 100
000 zeni for free the coupon code is
case sensitive so that's labyrinth g
no spaces capital l capital g
just click the link in the description
to start playing ragnarok labyrinth for
free
right now okay so after the release of
chapter 306 of the boku no hero manga
major anime news outlets including the
anime news network
reported that the manga is now entering
its final
arc the reason behind these new stories
seems to be the final page of chapter
306 and also the title of that chapter
which are the words the final act begins
now
after initially reporting that the final
arc was about to begin
the anime news network eventually
changed the title of their article from
final arc to final act
because act was the word used in the
official viz
translation but according to what the
anime news network
said in their update to the original
article the japanese kanji that was used
in the original japanese can be
translated both ways
so it could mean both arc and act as you
can imagine
all of this led to massive fan
speculation within the community and you
can't really blame people for freaking
out
if this really is the final arc then
even if it ends up being a very long
arc mha could be ending within a year or
so
that would be massive news for such a
popular and iconic
series and it would of course be
heartbreaking for so many long time fans
who look forward to the story every
single week
but if this is the final act rather than
the final
arc then we may not have to worry too
much
the final act is a much more general
term than final
arc and so a final story act could be
made up of multiple different arcs
maybe even multiple long arcs this means
that the manga could actually keep going
for several years
however regardless of whether this is
the final arc or the final act the
implication
is clear the mha manga is entering its
final
stages and whether these stages are
going to unfold over one arc or multiple
arcs
we really are getting closer and closer
to the epic conclusion
of the entire series and that in itself
is big news
and a big deal quick warning from this
point on in the video i will be
discussing
mha manga spoilers so proceed with
caution
you have been warned so the big question
now is what can we expect from the final
act
of the story with deku deciding to leave
the ua
before becoming a full-fledged hero the
story of my hero academia
is ironically moving away from the
academia
itself although to be fair deku could
always
change his mind and return and we could
also see the story checking in on the
other students who are still at ua
so i think it's still premature to say
that the ua will no longer be an
important part of the story
the last few arcs in the manga have been
by far the best arcs in the entire
series
in my opinion so i'm extremely excited
to see
where the story will go from here way
back in june of 2020 i made a video
addressing rumors
about the war arc potentially being the
final arc
in the story i can totally understand
why so many people were speculating that
the war arc might be the end
so many crazy things ended up happening
in this
most recent arcs so much changed so
quickly and the entire hero society
basically collapsed
i can't blame anyone for thinking that
this could be the build-up to some sort
of climactic
end but as i said back in that video at
the time
i did not believe that this war arc
would be the final
arc i believed that there would be more
arcs to come
but i did say that the war arc would
change everything we thought we knew
about boku no hero and i said that after
this arc
things would never be the same again
once the arc
did come to a conclusion many months
later that is exactly what happened
with the hero society collapsing the
massive villain prison breaks
and deku leaving the ua things will
definitely
never be the same again so what will
happen
now unless deku changes his mind and
returns to ua
we can expect that he will become a
vigilante obviously deku is not the type
of person to just stand by and do
nothing while all of this
crime and upheaval is happening
throughout the country protecting people
is kind of his whole thing and since he
can't do it as an official pro hero
we can assume that deku will do it as a
vigilante
and this in itself is a very interesting
concept
vigilantism is technically illegal so
will being a vigilante make deku more
likely to break the rules
in order to get the job done kind of
like batman the punisher and
other vigilantes with all of these
dangerous villains running around and
doing very dangerous things
i could totally see deku becoming a
darker character and being a lot more
willing to push the boundaries of
conventional morality
in the name of protecting the people or
i guess i should say that i would like
to see that happen with
deku's character so far deku has been
very wholesome
and morally upright which makes sense
for someone who wants to be a true hero
in the conventional sense
but being a vigilante is not the same as
being an official pro
hero so things could change and
speaking of vigilantes we have to talk
about stain
stain is now free as are many of the
other former prisoners from tartarus
and other prisons but here's the thing
about stain
he's not really a villain at least not
in the traditional sense
he does do villainous things but he does
them all in the name of what he
considers to be
true heroism stain doesn't break the law
because he wants money or power or
because he's just crazy and he wants to
see the world
burn stain breaks the law because he
believes that the current hero society
has become corrupt
and he thinks that the noble calling of
being a hero has been cheapened by
selfish and half-hearted heroes but
the hero society has completely changed
since the time that stain was first
arrested
one could argue that the hero society
that existed before the war arc has
basically collapsed
and ever since the tartarus prison break
first happened
i've been saying here on the channel
that stain is not going to be fighting
on the side of the villains
now that most of the opportunistic
half-hearted and self-centered heroes
have already retired
and now that the hero society itself has
practically crumbled
stains biggest problem won't be the
heroes
not anymore in his own twisted way stain
truly believes
in the ideal of heroism so i predict
that he will actually start fighting as
a vigilante to protect the people of
japan from villain attacks
in fact we might even get a deku stain
team
up sometime in the future stain already
acknowledged deku as a true hero worthy
of respect
so stain would probably have no problem
fighting side by side with deku and
don't get me wrong i don't think deku
will ever become friends with stain
deku will not simply forget the terrible
things that stain has done
but if the situation calls for it and
they are facing a common enemy
i could totally see vigilante stain and
vigilante deku
fighting together against the villains i
don't know about you guys but that is
something that i would freaking
love to see and speaking of the villains
we can expect them to only keep getting
stronger
in this final act i mean sure some of
the villains that escaped from prison
will just go off on their own and do
their own thing
but all for one is smart and i am sure
that he is going to gather the strongest
villains who escaped into his
own private army orchestrating six
additional prison breaks alongside the
tartarus prison break
wasn't just a random distraction tactic
you better believe that it was also a
recruitment
tactic and don't even get me started on
how strong shigaraki may possibly become
if all for one succeeds in completing
ujjiko's previously interrupted
procedure
so yeah the final act of the story is
going to be
insane the villains will be stronger
than ever before
the hero society will be in complete
chaos
deku may end up being a vigilante
alongside stain we may see
overpowered international heroes coming
to japan to help to fight against the
villains
and so much more we might even finally
figure out who the freaking ua traitor
is
remember that huge plot point from
earlier on in the story
nope that still hasn't been resolved
anyway let me know what you guys are
expecting to see in the final act and
how long do you think that this act
will last my guess is that the manga
will continue for at least another two
to three years because it is extremely
popular
and profitable and who knows maybe even
after the main story ends we're going to
get some kind of sequel like
mha the next generation or boku no hero
shipuden
man there is so much crazy potential so
i can't wait
to see how this final act is going to
unfold
don't forget to leave your thoughts down
in the comments
is deku going to become a vigilante and
maybe even team up
with stain do you think that we might
get a time skip
sometime in the near future will we ever
find
the ua trader let me know down below
if you enjoyed this video you want to
see more boku no hero content right here
on the channel please leave a like to
let me know it really does help
and if you are new to anime opera or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
please make this the video do you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at anime opera
thanks again to ragnarok labyrinth for
sponsoring this video
check them out link in the description
as always thank you guys so much for
watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you